the South Pacific nation of Kiribati is
a remote collection of islands scattered
along the equator across a distance the
width of the United States from the
turquoise lagoons you never guess that
these islands were the scene of one of
the bloodiest battles and US Marine
Corps history
today the island nation is being put on
the map again as the first country to be
erased from it
people in Kerry bus as it's known here
live just beyond the Dateline
every day they're among the first to see
the sunrise as one of the world's lowest
lying nations they're also among the
first to confront the impacts of climate
change
I buy young one of the outer islands of
Kerry boss has 6,000 residents who live
almost entirely off of the land and sea
our first stop is to boo Kanako back in
the 1970s it was a thriving coastal
village in the site of one of a by
Young's Maine harbors today it looks
like this
behind me you can kind of see the
remains this area has now been flooded
you can see where the water started to
enter the foundations are all that's
left of the two hundred households that
once lived around this Cove rising tides
have eroded the coasts and contaminated
the fresh water supply many of our young
friends have abandoned their homes and
scattered across the 33 islands of Kerry
boss you see that the coconut tree
mm-hmm yeah that's all up a pipe it's
all over my fix it - everyone banana
bananas and Dennis its root beer how
does it feel to see it underwater
very surprising are you scared for the
rest of a by young yes this church at
Manabe or community center were built
over a decade ago today the area has
been abandoned to flooding but the
people of Tabuk Kanako hope to preserve
these two structures the people in the
side of the beam up or lagoon they'd
already gone to the mainland
because 200 meters of their land
disappear and the people are lived there
remove and remove a separate right now
we're experiencing our total inundation
of areas that previously were not
vulnerable to normal tides and we're
getting something that we call king
tides which are actually extreme high
tides these were non-existence even when
I was a young boy Andrew team is the
president's senior advisor on climate
change
it's no longer a question of if we will
who will remain in the country forever
it's a matter of when we will have to
leave because the science is actually
very clean so what is the science saying
the basic physics of climate change is
very clear and very simple if the whole
ocean expands and if the old ocean
increases in temperature the volume will
expand the other part of the story is
that if the whole ice in the bottom
northern the southern and the mountain
areas actually melt all that volume of
ice will end up as water in the oceans
so if this actually turns out to be true
then maybe we wouldn't have more than
the rest of this century to stay here
what is the government doing right now
for each Erebus people who are affected
by climate change we need to start
worrying about what happens to the total
population when whether they go how will
they settle down will they be treated as
refugees can they be treated as refugees
kiri bus president anote a Tong has
lobbied for binding international
treaties to cut carbon emissions for
over a decade he's grown impatient with
the lack of urgency he's seen from
industrialized nations as the tides
continue to rise on his home that's a
global community we need to talk about
carbon emission levels we need to talk
about temperature rises but in fact what
will be achieved once those agreements
are reached is of no consequence to our
situation because we are already being
impacted and will continue to be
impacted whatever
the agreements reached at the
international level why is this
something that's personal to you not as
the president of Cuba's but as a family
man I have children I have a lot of
grandchildren with this and areas being
put forward by the climate scientists I
think there is real danger in their
future if nothing is done to raise the
level of the islands above the rising
seas then the reality would be that we
have to relocate out and so we are
preparing for that tong is one of the
world's first presidents forced to plan
the gradual demise of his country due to
climate change
faced with the need to move its people
in masse the government of Cuba is
sending citizens abroad to Australia and
New Zealand for job and skills training
preparing them for when they'll have to
leave for good they call the effort
migration with dignity I went in one of
my grades and be
he classified as a refugee anyway I
really prefer to move to an area where I
can settle down and neck like anybody
else in that society only the Fiji
government and the people have
definitely come forward to say yes we
will assist kill but if ever there is
reason for them to relocate no other
nation no other country has ever come
forward with that just a few miles from
the kiri boss Parliament the village of
a toss stands amidst an ever-rising
swamp residents fear it may soon face
the same fate as the underwater villages
of a bay on the home of fifteen-year-old
Roubaix was once an oceanside sanctuary
until more frequent king tides engulfed
the property now her family lives in a
perpetual state of construction building
and rebuilding sea walls to fortify
their children and livelihoods if you
recall earlier there were about 20
meters of beach here and some of who
faced family members building a wall now
there's about two meters worth of water
and flooding in some of the areas just
behind the wall Ruby's family hopes to
send her overseas for a better life
where are we yep good it fast yeah okay
but where will you go in New Zealand Oh
gone
they haven't been selected for the
government's migration with dignity
program so they're making their own
arrangements yanti da she's trying to
find a way through the immigration in
the adoption yes so that she can live
with it in New Zealand are you excited
yeah excited I said what are you sad
about missing here how about missing our
places missing of foreign friends
Ruby's grandmother fears for the
family's future here in a DA we have
tried to build up the seawall many times
are still broken here their burger yeah
we're all the guys want to go huh the
masternodes is a safe place yes
as climate change forces families to
relocate nearly half the country's
population has moved to the nation's
capital island of south tarawa this mass
migration has made it one of the most
populated areas on earth with a density
similar to that of Tokyo or Gaza the
overcrowding has caused other problems
like pollution disease and poor
sanitation problems that may further
threaten the freshwater supply it's like
walking through a minefield here the
rising tide isn't just bringing water
it's also bringing tons and tons of
trash that combined with thousands of
people who are moving to higher ground
is threatening the little bit of land
that's still left we already had our
development those challenges
waste-disposal solid waste disposal is a
problem the utilities are stressed and
so we have all of that and this is being
compounded by the fact that we have to
attend to the challenges of climate
change tomato is one of the most
vulnerable sites in south tarawa it's
also just a few short miles from the
islands primary freshwater aquifer a
single wave across this thin strip of
land could leave the water supply
contaminated for up to two years this
place is a get better by sea water every
high tide see the many sea walls that
they have dead from the different times
that the tide has come to wash them away
and they keep building rebuilding and
rebuilding colonies alofa is a community
organizer who helps Pacific Islanders
deal with the impact of the rising seen
much of her focus is on the over 60% of
the carry bus population under 30 these
young people could be the last
generation to live on these islands what
would you want young care
live in other countries to know about
the country that they are not even I
want them to know that they used to come
from a very beautiful country now in the
world he's got a big they got the most
beautiful ocean you know if wherever
they go they will never have this kind
of ocean anymore
they will never have that connection
with their pupil with their land that
they used to have for Paolini say the
current threat of displacement has an
element of deja vu her family is from
the Kerry bass island of banaba where in
the 1940s residents were forcibly
relocated to Fiji by a British mining
company we lost touch of the island our
island incurables because the company
took over they just mined almost
everything away for an indigenous person
you always have that spiritual
connection to your land and the
connection really is through your
ancestors they come up with the stories
the stories of who we are as Akira best
people right from the beginning how
would you feel if you had to leave your
ancestors here in carapace I do not want
anyone ever to experience you know
forced migration no because we were
actually forced to leave and I do not
want anyone because of climate change
you live there country despite the
challenges the Cuba's people are finding
ways to resist their fate we plan Negros
to protect our coasts our land you see
when you plant this kind of mangroves
they are like wave breakers how long
does it take to grow few weeks
no is that very new roots mangrove trees
can grow in salty water and are an
affordable way for communities to
preserve their coastline and so it's
protecting this end from erosion we said
it's a seed all right well it falls it
falls this way actually and so that's
why they grow see all this one they fall
from this and it just it's back in the
soil and grow so what we do we just go
in and collect all this and distribute
it among our youth and we start planting
three at a time
fluorine and Turanga are determined to
save their school and their Island we
have done a report for investigating
whether the coastal erosion is really
exists in our air especially on the Isle
our school Loreen began to research her
school's receding coastline when she
noticed that the beach used to play on
was quickly disappearing so you guys are
very focused on collecting the evidence
that proves climate it's not only the
walls but only the trees and the sand
whether we can know whether the settings
have been washed away but without
international support they know that
their efforts will not be enough she
found out that the the outer country
some they have bigger factories than us
yeah that factory is actually also
contributing to the furniture so we
would like to either go helping her hand
to the bigger countries yeah yeah I'm
trying to gather in cooperating
industry yeah as you can understand my
greatest concern was for my people what
is to be the future of our young in the
early stages my answer would have been
nothing there is nothing we can do it's
beyond our control but I couldn't accept
that because it's not good enough we
gotta come forward with innovative
solutions as a country without industry
carry boss has no carbon emissions to
cut what they do have is tuna and in an
effort to set an example for
industrialized nations president Tong
launched the Phoenix island protected
area or PIPA a marine reserve that would
secure the world's tuna supply for
future generations we thought that we
would do this as part of our statement
to the international community that yes
all nations have to make sacrifices in
order to address the issue of climate
change no matter how desperately we need
the revenue from this nevertheless it is
our contribution yet despite their
willingness to sacrifice neither the
people of carry biased or their
government have the leverage to change
the country's fate in 2015 the
international community will convene at
the UN climate summit in Paris it is
hoped that they will set binding targets
for countries to cut carbon emissions an
agreement that won't be implemented
until 2020 for low-lying island nations
these measures will be too little too
late climate change even if its impact
Scarabus right now and is undermining
our development and all that it's not a
bad Carabas alone it's about our whole
world here we are testing the human
values how do people respond when they
find out as in the situation like this
and we may be on the front line going
down first it will reach everyone in
right in the end
Oh